l'épreuve des cylindres chez vous
éloignez peut-être déjà deux enfants les
plus jeunes participent alors à
une caméra qu'il est évidemment c'est
kate middleton kate le pen s'est tenue à
hawaï abl ça c'est encore eux ça ça
c'est ouais 500000 exemplaires mais
également le plus gros procès c'est ça
c'est pour ça qu'on a parmi la photo à
oui voilà exactement déjà il ya eu je
crois une réédition de vrais du du
journal ce qui est assez rare surtout
depuis la rue 2000 2010 où la presse
devant moi et mais par contre il ya eu
une amende record et surtout ça
terriblement sachets la presse anglaise
la presse anglaise qui s'est refusé à
publier les photos qui en a parlé de
façon qu'on pourrait même en parler avec
bertrand de façon très violente à
l'égard des français qui avaient osé
c'est une attaque à la couronne il
semble qu'il ya eu 45000 euros d'amendé
pour les deux dirigeants et 10000 pour
le photographe mais c'est finalement si
finalement la photo est vendu
pour toi pourquoi s'arrêter sert alors
atteindre succès indépendant c'est à
dire que cette photo là je vais être
très sincère je ne sais pas mais ce qui
arrive parfois si tu peux vendre en
france et à l'international
et là par contre là c'est le jackpot
johnny hallyday était 97 qu'est ce qui
est bien et ce qui se passe et et 97
tromper je pense pas que des 97 était la
première fois mais qu'il fasse chaud p
effectivement c'était plus embêtant et
non mais voilà ce qui est hallucinant
quand même c'est que vous savez sur 1000
exemplaires si je me dis aussi mais
c'est que pour pas que laëtitia le sache
il la mène en croisière mal en se disant
elle le sera parce que au moment de
l'édition est la seconde cause elle va
revenir il ya toute la famille qui va
lui dire est que deux passions est le
sort a donc ça c'est quand même facile
jaunies ce qui se passe sur cette une
c'est quand même à l'époque c1 c'est un
séisme pour johnny mais surtout pour
laetitia parce que à ce moment là elle
croit vraiment on a souvent dit que
c'est un couple libre machine pas du
tout à l'époque elle elle croise qui se
sont jurés et c'est la fidélité alors
que les milieux règne
ça quand elle découvre ça me rase et
repartir il a vraiment failli là qui
agressent à un pas sans à-coups de
louboutin à
miami mais ses yeux ça je peux mourir
chaque gros péter tout péter je suis
trop bt n'a pas faibli moi qui m'ont
privé d'alcool
c'est vrai qu'elle est drôle mais c'est
marrant de voir maintenant l'évolution
qu'a émanant de deux
gamins on savait qu'ils allaient
remettre qu'elle tac je tutoie mais il
ya quand même une réputation au club où
tu me diras magali soudain pense parfois
si vous êtes ami tu me dira peut-être
pas la vérité mais tout cas une certaine
violence quand même elle et thomas ces
deux personnes quand même qu'ils
sanguinaire du
ca à couteaux tirés
par exemple sur l'épreuve des cylindres
il n'existe plus parce qu'elle a été
jugée sexiste voilà vraiment genre bon
tu peux dépasser ça a été magnifique
donc si vous faites quelque chose j'aime
pas une question est magnifique c'est
qu'effectivement par et demi tout à
l'heure avec nelson mais depuis cette
depuis août où cette épreuve a été
retirée absolument cinq ans
impressionnant relève l'esa les tigres
étaient plus
du dépassement de soi mais je trouve ça
bien pour nous enlever cette ces grandes
par exemple ça très bien très bien mais
franchement tu veux pas qu'on fasse a
dit m non mais tu peux la passé mais moi
ce que je veux dire c'est que c'est
quand même tout chaque jour il y en a
qui ont fait cette épreuve c'est un truc
qui vous colle à la peau d'accord c'est
le cas de le dire mais la valeur mais
encore aujourd'hui la preuve bada mais
si tu me dis en revanche ça a été un
supplice le pack all eyes
on le
faisait rire jaune quoi mais c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
l'épreuve des cylindres chez vous
éloignez peut-être des gens les enfants
les plus jeunes les abonderait strip
tease sur regardez c'est anne gaëlle
riccio sur l'épreuve des 6 la nuit
l'avant et après baptisé plus c'est
parti alors
on est venus pour réussir avant la clé
tx de toujours là fixé ça c'est très
important elle va tailler permet d'avoir
une certaine équipe que tu peux lui dire
si ces deux d'entourer les cylindres
avec ses jambes
ne sont pas que les cours sont le crir
ok
je lutterai les mots du
voyage et mentalement
elle est vraiment frais sur wii et a
encore du temps
[Musique]
elle a un énorme avantage c'est qu'elle
est plutôt menue et déjà les a
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toujours été magnifique c'est un peu
choquant effectivement envoyé des images
c'est qu'on voit quand même que le real
zoom
fille qu'on en voyait faire cette
épreuve l'année mais d'autres buts que
montrer la plastique comme dans koh
lanta l'épreuve de l'abonné n'a d'autre
but que la serre et les femmes en sous
vêtements qui la boue comment moi je
rectifie faire
par exemple j'ai droit à l'écarteur
dedans
je perds le silence
en fin d'audience
c'est vrai que les gens
il aurait permis shirt est juste un tee
shirt et maintenir l'épreuve parce que
moi ça me choque pas tant que ça fait
quatre fois en débardeur et envoyer des
hommes de temps en temps surtout on
demandait à voir autre chose qu'un
débardeur et on nous disait toujours
nommés et petites chaînes canal+ que ça
le problème je viens c'est ça juste
comme ça
les hommes et les
femmes